deep deep welcome back we are in our new
place
alright yes here this is our first
podcast in our new house
and let's just get all the disclosures
out of the way first okay go for it just
close on me daddy I put up a total of
five panels of sound foam in this room
because I ran out of spray today so it's
gonna be a bit echoey we are recording
off of this [ __ ] thing because our
podcast PC is not currently here we
can't record through our normal audio
program we have a window open currently
because we don't know how the
ventilation will work or the sound with
that or whatever but you have light but
we do have we have cool new lights but
yeah so if it sounds kind of weird guys
the audio might be a little funky this
week yeah we should talk about the
lights a little bit it talked about well
we got these first of all even first of
all it's pretty nuts to be recording it
in this room right now doesn't it trippy
yeah cuz there's no gaming setup and
there's like no desk off to the side
like I don't feel crunched in here yeah
and we if you guys have been you know
keeping up with the blogs and whatnot we
have like a bigger monitor now so we can
see ourselves it's nice I mean it
definitely doesn't feel as crammed as
before that's an understatement
yeah I can't believe that we functioned
in that room it like shouldn't have been
possible I know I look at pictures I'm
like I get anxiety about it it shouldn't
have been possible anyway these lights
are from a company called aperture and
they are not a sponsor of the podcast
but they have supported us in a big way
by supplying us with two really really
hefty nice lights we have the 120 d with
a light dome and then we have the LED
panel over there and it's not like
blazing hot lights with the old bulbs
like we've yeah we bought these lights
off of amazon for our podcast and for
Jenna's videos
and you screw this big old industrial
bulb into it and you put the umbrella on
it and then it just heats up and it
can't stay on for more than Linc all
right now it's so hot but it gets it
gets the room so hot these are giving up
literally no heat there's a fan on the
back of the 120 and there's that's you
can touch that and doesn't even get hot
so if you're looking for some lighting
if you definitely recommend yeah and
I'll link them below guys I'll also
probably tweet them out or something on
the on this account
but yeah it's been it's been nice to
have this because if we had to like come
into our new our new room and podcast
and still get really hot from those
lights that were to suck yeah well you'd
also get boiling hot when you're gaming
tooks who use those lights as well yeah
sure so hot all the time I know and I'm
already so hot time yeah okay can we
open the window I'm like yeah dude ever
you want you're like are you hot and
like no I'm not that like perfect I feel
like I asked you if you're hot so often
and you're just like no and I'm like
like you're not hot no like last night I
was like sweating why I just moved fast
and then like I just generate heat I
think you just have a lot of muscle mass
that just like makes you feel real hot
all the time okay let's go with that
let's go with that all those muscles boy
they need food they make it heat they
have yeah oh my god oh my I would say my
pet peeve though is when you you turn on
the air-conditioning and then decide
that you're still hot so you like open
the door or window to it I'm like you
just turn on the air-conditioning you
can't do that that's no no I don't
remember the absolutely note I don't
remember don't do that or when you turn
on the air-conditioning but it's cooler
outside that is with the air
conditioning on it's true open the
window or the door it's tricky okay I'm
not it's not a weatherman I don't know
the temperature outside and inside at
all times sometimes you just got to
experiment just open the door and see if
it's cool outside and then it's open
like the window okay
anyway um what we're on week two and a
half of settling into our new house now
and it's like finally starting to feel
like our home yeah I mean we still have
a lot of work to do and will in the
future but I mean we have enough right
now to function which is really nice
although I still don't have a desk my
desk is apparently coming tomorrow
supposedly it was supposed to come last
week I know but once we at your desk
yeah we hang up some art yeah and we do
a couple other things that's really
gonna like feel like our house which is
nice because I mean we love our new home
but we still want to keep making it ours
also the dogs are in here yeah if you
haven't noticed there's been no barking
because we're not next to a street I put
there by top of those thanks to me like
directly to my left here because their
bed was over there but they didn't want
to sit over there they were too far from
me so I moved over here and now they're
all sitting quietly yeah I think the the
the lack of barking in this house is
like spectacular cuz it's not you know
right in the middle of everything like
people would just walk past our house
all day there were dogs close to a place
where a lot of people would park to go
to work because you could just Park on
our street so like a lot of people would
walk to like where they would work right
near her house there was just constantly
people and dogs and kids all kinds of
the noises so they were so loud in that
last house and they are so quiet here
yeah because there's just less to Barket
yeah it's been really nice they also
have such a better outdoor situation
here like being outside I have a hell of
a sunburn going on in my legs right now
because I literally have not been
outside I know it's years it's been so
nice it's just like like lay in the Sun
somewhere where you're not like
completely uncomfortable yeah like in
our own place like I don't know there's
something about like low walls to where
your head pops up above them it's just
like in your backyard it's like why even
have a wall well yeah I mean you can
just see your neighbors I mean that's a
case in most large cities is like even
if you have an outdoor space it's like
sort of private because you have to
build your own privacy you know what I
mean first of all we do have much more
privacy here which has been
I don't know just getting to go outside
and like make vitamin D through my skin
has been really great considering what
was prescribed that kind that I only
take once the week it's looks strong and
my doctor was like laughing at me he's
like exactly it was good vitamin D yeah
he's like there's you know 300 days of
sunshine here like why are you so
vitamin D deficient I'm like do I look
like the kind of person that goes
outside but like now I can it's been
really yeah we went swimming this
weekend it's like what is even happening
we have a pool it's like great yeah it's
been nice the dogs are happy yeah the
dogs are much happier yeah as we say
that hey you know I like you're making
us literally a bunch of liars over here
all right got that nasty mouth we do
have those same giant crows here that we
did at the last place
Kermit like I had those pool chairs that
I've had for years like from our old
house like when we lived in Westwood and
they had these couch cushions and we got
them like sort of around the time that
we got peach yeah and they were like
really good for a little while and then
the cushions started like coming apart
it was like super ripped up and I my
initial instinct was because peach was
like a destroyer she chewed everything I
thought she was going out there when I
wasn't looking and destroying my pool
chairs and I was getting so mad at her
she was wrongfully accused well to be
fair I saw her like taking the stuffing
out and playing with it because there
were holes in it and the stuffing was
exposed so she really liked it I
literally just cut the podcast I'm sorry
I I forgot we didn't have our full audio
setup here so now it should sound a
little bit better maybe yeah question
mark no it really does there's less hiss
yeah thanks for being patient with us
OVA Ares around that's right we are one
collective Ares this week we're doing
some cool we're playing in a little pub
G tournament have they not that yeah
they haven't they're always pretty late
with announcing these things but its the
twitch rivals tournament that we're
gonna play in and should be exciting
we've done a couple of them before Jenna
me Jason and mr. Chris Mel Berger will
be playing as a team we're gonna be
playing
mode yeah I got to get my video done on
Tuesday in order to play because the
tournaments are always on Wednesdays
yeah they're always on a Wednesday they
are I was this have anything that you
want me to make please leave them in the
comments below honestly I'm done using
Facebook for asking people for
suggestions it is so frustrating this is
pointless it's it's point I hate
Facebook
I hate logging onto Facebook I literally
I post my video and then it [ __ ]
leave every week it's not that I hate
the people on Facebook it's just like
platform astir platform is really I just
don't enjoy it yeah well I mean believe
it or not guys like each week when we go
like to figure out what we're gonna do
for a podcast like I go to the you know
we go to the previous week's podcast to
just check the comment section because
you guys drop good suggestions all the
time so India funny any funny
so yeah dude your suggestions and
comments like they absolutely help us
for generous videos like yes whoever's
been suggesting to make Kermit a bed of
Irish Spring soap so that he can roll
around in it I see your comedy
we actually like sat down and tried to
we looked up like what the process is
how to do it but we the problem that we
ran into is that I don't have anything
to mold a bed out of like we could melt
the soap down a problem but then I have
nothing to mole you can buy molds for
like small things like a cup or a bowl
but I need to make them yeah and I don't
really know how to do that because it
can't be something hard it has to be
like soft that you can like pop it out
of I've watched face off I know they
have that thing where yeah exactly
vacuum is so nice that's I want to look
up compilations of the vacuform on the
youtube doctor it has to be compilations
it is really so satisfying to jockey for
me oh yeah I missed his show
it's a great job where did it go well
he's still a John Deere stop we just
haven't watched it
porque um one thing that I think is
interesting about when we moved in here
we went we had what Time Warner Cable or
whoever come to set up our TVs DirecTV
DirecTV and in our old place we had
DirecTV and they came to set up the
boxes and they were like yeah there's no
cable
like in the living room there's no cable
to like have cable you have to call a
separate company to come and like it's
hardwired your house yeah hardwire your
house for cable and roams like oh my god
no like he'd do that and I was like no I
think it's I think it would be okay if
we just like didn't have cable no I want
credit cuz I was the one who said that I
was like is it time don't we cut the
cord well yeah at first I was like we
can we didn't figure it out well cuz it
was never a big issue list yeah like he
was like oh you can't in your main
living room you can't have cable or at
right now and then we were like okay
that's like that's fine we pretty much
firm cast everything except for like
right survivor anyway yeah well we have
like Hulu and Netflix so we cut the cord
yes so we're that we don't have any
cable we are official cord cutters happy
being a millennial yeah but I mean one
thing that I have been using which was
nice was remember when YouTube TV first
came out and I was like I think I got
the trial subscription and then like a
dumbass just never cancelled yeah yeah
exactly it's just been Otto or doing but
I also like as much as we [ __ ] on
YouTube and they make mistakes in my
opinion that they need to be called out
on which they are currently doing still
I've missed a lot of stuff since we've
been off the podcast for a little bit
but like there's a lot of stuff going on
YouTube that's not super great but I
still in my heart of hearts want to
support YouTube and you know i have a
youtube red subscription I pay for
YouTube music and I do pay for YouTube
TV so it doesn't make me upset like I
want to support YouTube and the platform
and creators as a whole but I was only
using YouTube's TV when it came out on
my iPad in the kitchen because I would
sit there and like eat breakfast and
watch like whatever old a Star Trek was
on you know yeah yeah like a brat like I
want to I want to watch TV at my kitchen
table but now that we don't have cable
it's actually been really nice because
you can chromecast it to your TV yeah
and like the features that it gives you
is like you know you can record sort of
stuff like you would do on your DVR
whatever but yes it's nice like whatever
yeah forget what we were I do it I have
some complaints like it's there's some
bugs there's some stuff
I don't understand it like they're
making a little complicated to figure
out like feeling that I got that error
message on the screen and it wouldn't go
away that was stats for nerds yeah and
then I had recorded a movie that I
wanted to watch i wanted to watch
casablanca which by the way i went off
on the i went off i want to hear your
own popular opinion puffin right here
we'll get there so youtube TVs like
alright if you choose to record a show
will record it for you when it airs on
live TV and then you can watch it back
like whenever you want yeah so Julian
had gone out to the west side to go hang
out with his friends for like a Saturday
night or whatever and I was like all
right I'm gonna get tucked in the couch
I'm like I'm in my new house I'm feeling
homey
I'm gonna watch a movie which is
embarrassing I've never actually seen
Casablanca still to this moment yeah so
I was like now's a great time those of
you adults like me or you know people
that don't have the opportunity to sit
down and watch movie all the time like
you appreciate me like I'm missing this
big piece of like culture in my life
that I you know should probably absorb
at some point which by the way spoiler
alerts if you haven't seen Casablanca
we might spoil it I don't think I'm
gonna spoil it but it's well how I feel
about coming home to here you just like
[ __ ] on Casablanca so well because
Julian was gone and I watched Casablanca
and then I watched Citizen Kane which I
had also Trixie which I have seen that
one yeah but Julia you went to school
and studied like film and that kind of
stuff it was part of our education but
um so I had recorded that movie to watch
on YouTube TV and I start playing back
the recording and it's like one of those
shows where they're sitting down and
like talking about the film beforehand
and they're like so it's like five
minutes of that so I'm sort of sitting
through that like okay this is fine you
know there probably be commercials like
I wish I could watch it the whole way
through but like I understand it's on
live TV so they're gonna there's gonna
be commercials or whatever in the
recorded version so I started watching
and then all of us I don't know what
happened but it was like you know when
you like a blind person watches TV and
it's not
closed-captions that someone like
describing what's happening yeah so the
film starts and it's like a shield
appears with words over it and blah blah
blah and I'm like oh my god I don't know
how to turn this off like it's not just
closed captions it's this woman shouting
like what's going on and described
everything in the film and I was like no
disrespect but like I can't watch this
and that it was a setting that wasn't
properly on that wasn't yes so were or
that channel had had it on permanently
but I was like okay I can't like I'm
trying to focus here I'm just trying to
watch this movie that I feel I can't
even watch for whatever reason I can't
have this be my experience shouting
she's like a busy marketplace appears
and people are moving all around it's
like so I couldn't watch it yeah yeah
well cuz it's it's sensory overload cuz
you're trying to watch and listen right
yes it is sensory overload so I went to
go I had to download it on your Amazon
account that's what that was about watch
it on my phone oh speaking of Amazon
we'll get to that what your rack Julian
I'm gonna hear about Casablanca first
totally what what did I do so well I
mean to be fair when you came home I had
drank a fair amount of white wine I was
like I was heated but um I didn't go to
film school I didn't like my mom loves
old black-and-white movies like she
watches them all the Turner Classic
Movies is like what our TV is always on
so I feel like I've seen a lot of movies
sort of like in pieces secondhand I get
the vibe I get whatever and I had sort
of built Casablanca up into my own mind
as this like quintessential viewing of
film like whatever yeah and I understand
the backstory it was like 1942 it was
released the war was not resolved people
were very unsure about where things were
going and it's about Morocco I think I
don't like getting drunk because they're
like all of the people they're getting
pushed out of their countries as the
Germans sort of invade are trying to
flee to Lisbon to where they can get to
the United States
but not everyone could get to Lisbon so
a lot of people were stuck sort of in
Morocco and then they would have to take
a plane or a ship or something to Lisbon
if they were lucky or if they had a
connection or money to flee Europe
basically and it's about it takes place
like in Morocco where everyone's in this
sort of like limbo that they're
essentially like refugees
you know good-looking ones and movie
ones and like okay and they introduce
the main character it's just like a
[ __ ] dick like he's such a dick like
oh I know I have to be alone like that I
I know everyone's gonna [ __ ] on me like
you don't appreciate it you don't
understand it that's fine okay just let
me be a [ __ ] because Julian was laughing
really hard when I was going off about
it like to look at it from a 20-18 lens
it is so [ __ ] stupid it's so stupid
like all I get the the commentary about
the war and the tension at that point
that's not what I'm ragging on
I'm ragging on the fact that none of the
filmmaking in it is profound whatsoever
like watching that movie to me
because I watched this in Kane which
came out a year before that I get it
okay like oh the shots are profound the
lighting is profound that the use of
shadows it was really groundbreaking
really groundbreaking I got it I wasn't
a huge fan I think what I said to you is
Citizen Kane is like the jerk but not
funny at all and that's honestly a
really it's just a rags
it's a funny it's a funny observation
like if you if you've seen the jerk jerk
came out like 30 years later and 40
years later that type of stories which
is why it's so hysterically yeah I got
it's so stupid but Casablanca to me I
was like so disappointed in the way that
this is supposed to be such like a
romantic movie like they literally met
each other like during a day or a week
or some undisclosed amount of time then
it's it's a love story amidst
chaos right like that's during the war
so but like my question is like I'm sure
a lot of people who in 2018 still value
Casablanca right like there's a lot of
people and I'm sure the people who do
don't really try to fit that movie into
today do you like do you know I'm
totally just playing devil's advocate
like do you think that people who are
fans of that movie like can appreciate
it although yeah absolutely laughable
and in the sense of like the 20 2018
scope absolutely I mean that's why you
can appreciate anything that you know
doesn't necessarily make sense today
like it doesn't have to make sense
in my mind I was like this is supposed
to be this great fantastic movie you
know it's like this is [ __ ] dumb this
is so dumb yeah I mean it feel free to
[ __ ] on me in the comments okay it's my
opinion I feel like really sorry if I'm
offending I feel like there's gonna be a
few hardcore sitting on you but I do
weirdly feel like there's gonna be a lot
of people agreeing with you because like
I don't know like something about like
you know people on the internet now who
are exposed to so much content all the
time can look at old things where our
parents are like you will like them yeah
I mean don't don't get it twisted I
appreciated it I understand it I
understand the importance of it at the
time but but from my perspective it was
just a man who knew what was best for
everybody else and acted on that the
entire time so why do just I appear Lee
out of curiosity because I have you
deciding romantic about it and I said to
you - how is there nothing romantic
about it I think Casablanca is literally
like it's like a it's a shorthand term
for love like people say oh look at this
Casablanca over there like that Bergman
or whatever her name is
it's like 30 years younger than him and
he's just like nasty smoking cigarettes
like drinking like it is it makes me
feel nothing other than just like what
the [ __ ]
it really just pissed me off it really
did I know I'm thinking about don't have
an unpopular opinion today I have a
question which one did you watch the
movies in came first no I watched
Casablanca firs
hmm why I'm just I'm just thinking I was
just sitting there and I was like this
is my reaction that was like what like
that's it well that's also it that's
also a problem when you have this
colossal like standard to live up to
when everyone and their mom is forever
talking about how much of a legendary
movie it isn't in you're like okay I'll
watch it and then of course your
expectations like way up here right so
if it doesn't blow your mind you're like
okay right well I mean what I did also
say to you to that night like again I
was drunk okay I'm gonna say it funny
[ __ ] I was going off it's like I didn't
like Citizen Kane that much I
appreciated the filmmaking in
cinematography but I was like again not
my cup of tea I'm not gonna watch it I
don't know no thank you
but um I [ __ ] I just forgot what I was
gonna say whatever it doesn't matter
yeah I was it was funny at the time cuz
I was ripping on like arguably two of
the greatest films to ever exist Oh what
I was gonna say it was I think I said
something stupid along the lines of like
those movies made me feel nothing like I
feel more watching you know trash
television at this point like I feel
more connected to human nature than that
those storytelling movies told me but
that I did appreciate that they were
original stories and that I feel like
Hollywood at this point when you go to
the movies and you you have this like
emptiness when you see a film because
you're like I don't feel anything like I
feel yeah because they make more money
pumping out another [ __ ] Avengers
movie or what I'm not please don't come
for me okay I'm just trying to see facts
they make more money pumping out like
sequels to popular movies and not really
stretching the the story it's not that I
don't think that great stories exists I
think that there's not necessarily in
cinemas anymore right whereas you know
during that age of storytelling in film
there were great stories because I feel
like they were taking a lot of that from
theatres which have these like beautiful
first second third acts like a proper
climax it was like the early days of
filmmaking to where it was like no like
there were there was so much to create
that hadn't been created in that medium
right but they
they did they had a like a proper
storytelling a proper climax no proper
beginning middle and end yeah
so you do feel like you watch a complete
foam whereas now you can watch some hot
steaming pile of garbage [ __ ] starring a
very you know popular professional actor
actress and you're like I hate it yeah
that was a piece of [ __ ] yeah that was
really well made and produced and filmed
but sorry I would watch I would watch
okay what I said to you but it was
really funny
I would watch a video of you reviewing
Casablanca like with it what live yeah
live like we like go and rabbit and play
Casablanca and just that be reacting to
it it was really funny because I would
watch I was laughing to myself at one
point I kind of been paused it to go pee
and I was just like I was drunk but I'm
sitting there I'm going dude what the
[ __ ] to myself and good times
no I said to you I mean it seems kind of
dramatic now but I think back on it but
I was sort of upset with the way that
the women were portrayed in these movies
which is again like I understand this is
like we're pushing 75 years ago now like
the way different times totally get it
but I said to Julia I was like thinking
the Statue of David right we can all
agree that it's carved beautifully it's
an amazing piece of art right you're
like the Sistine Chapel like I think
that you can appreciate the art now
imagine the Statue of Dave you've never
seen it before but people keep telling
you you've got to go see it you get it's
amazing but that you show up it's a
statue of David and he's choking a woman
to death I get it like I think it's
really nice
and yet wow the talent of that artist is
really spectacular but like I'm just I'm
just not feeling I totally forgot that
you said that it's so funny like it
those two movies weren't even really
that bad in terms of like I just it made
me feel like it made me laugh
it made me angry it made me feel like
well this is stupid
and I also was like I can't believe that
this is how like love was portrayed so
that's so funny
is it though or am I just like sort of
an [ __ ] like I think favorite movie
if I'm being perfectly honest I think
it's funny and I think it's like it's
interesting hearing your rant but at the
same time knowing you I know you and I
know you like to go against the grain in
the way that like if society tells you
that this movie is a classic you're
gonna really look out and be like well
is it really is it a classic is it a
classic you're gonna look at the movie
is it a clap are you a classic and the
movies gonna blush you feel embarrassed
and you're gonna call it not classic and
you're gonna break it down that's what
you do I mean it's like it's funny but
it's also like really Jenna of you yeah
well okay so I'll say Citizen Kane I
think is a classic filmmaking movie I
think that that's an important part of
an education well and also like having
been through that system of like film
school where like I didn't necessarily
know what I wanted to do I was just like
this is the most interested I've been in
all the majors I've tried to share so
I'm here in this class with a whole
bunch of [ __ ] people in the seer in
the lecture hall watching this movie in
black and white and I don't know what it
is obviously at first I'm like not super
intrigued by because I'm not like I'm
not the kid next to me who's like I want
to be a director I can't you know cuz
there's so many of those kids in film
schools or just like I want to be direct
there's of course nothing wrong with
that but that just wasn't me and so like
me watching that film back then I
remember thinking like okay like I'm not
really interested but I'm gonna try to
take it for what it's worth and and now
that I think back to all the things that
I did and that in that program like I
get it and I know why it's a special
film and I'm glad they teach that film I
think they make sense right I understand
from that perspective why that's that's
an important part of your education you
know what I mean there did I like it
not the [ __ ] really honestly it's like
really bored
Julianne had already come home at that
point and I was like just waiting for it
to end
fair enough you know like I saw some of
the beautiful shots and shadows and like
they had to be that creative because
y'all had black and white film okay
like again like such a Genest Ament yeah
had to be that clear because you didn't
have a color in your film let's greet
[ __ ] stand behind this palm tree and let
the shadow get on your jacket oh that's
a nice look upon that but and Casso and
I will say for Casablanca I do think
that it's an important piece of work
during a very uncertain time like the
the social implications of that film I
understand yeah
is it a love story I think the [ __ ] not
I think the [ __ ] not well it's
definitely not a 20-18 love story I'm
like the development of their
relationship I was just completely not
invested in it was a do the protagonist
male is just a misogynist I mean it's
not with me all right you know what this
this makes me think like we should have
a monthly yeah
anyway we reviewed on the podcast no no
like or like a I was thinking like Jen
and Jillian's like book club but it's
like movie club like we watch an old
ancient film that you guys request once
a month and on the podcast we can give
our sides of what we thought of it I
think that'd be good because there would
be so many moments of you being like
it's trash I don't think it's right I
don't think it's like I don't think it's
a it's reputation is what it deserves
and I'm gonna be like well it's
beautiful and we'll just go at it yeah I
mean I can think of a couple like like I
think there could be some good ones no I
agree well I mean I like a lot of older
movies I they really they're Roman
Holiday Spectacular loved it
Breakfast at Tiffany's thought it was
great have you seen Blazing Saddles
absolutely I mean that's not quite as
old as we're talking
no but that's older some like it hot
like that kind of stuff yeah what's the
oldest movie that you like hmm I guess I
don't know yeah me neither
I don't know the link never mind what I
think I thought I was gonna I thought
about a movie but I realized how not old
it was oh what'd you think a league of
their own
what it takes place old it takes place
in like the thirties forties didn't
color yeah sepia Sofia Sofia literally
starring Madonna and Geena Davis and Tom
Hanks like is Geena Davis the one in
stewar little yes or no is that is Geena
Davis do er littles mom I think it is I
think you might she's the one who plays
dotty I think you got an a right it's -
a little it's a good phone mmm
couple of them Wow what um I'm just
trying to think like that if we did that
I think it'd be really funny but like
Clockwork Orange
[ __ ] love it disturbing movie crazy
but like it just hits you in this
visceral place of you're just like it it
made me feel something yeah yeah I get
whenever I'm consuming anything you know
that's why I like YouTube so much cuz I
feel like you get that feeling cuz
you're watching real people you're the
most part yeah you know some of its
orchestrated but like when you watch
something that makes that connects with
you on a visceral like level that's
really all I'm looking for when I'm
watching content like there are better
shows on Hulu that make me feel like the
handmade sale are you [ __ ] serious in
order for me to like a show the the
context or a movie like it doesn't
matter if has anything to do with me
like I just need to feel something in
order to feel like I've enjoyed it I
mean even that's I think that's true for
a lot of people I think that's what
resonates with people is like if they
can if they can walk away get off that
couch move on with their day like
nothing happened then it's like okay it
was great but whatever but if you if
you're thinking about a days and days
later you're like damn it man yeah
that's some [ __ ] art right there that
made me feel so [ __ ] hard it's crazy
it's crazy though cuz clock regards is a
great example cuz I when you show me
that movie and I watch it with you I was
like I had no idea what to expect I was
like III don't know how do you expect
that for
my movie and then no and then that movie
I don't know it just spoken like to to
true film amateurs over here
we should start a second podcast called
the film amateur podcast but like what
what I'm saying though is that I have
the ability to appreciate a movie for
what it is and what it was like I'm not
I'm not really ragging on anything like
I'm just saying I feel like that film
Casablanca in particular is hyped up is
this like love story of all love stories
because it's you know the backdrop is a
war and there's just like a lot of
conflict going on everything's uncertain
and it was a mirror of the times I
[ __ ] get it it made me feel like a
piece of [ __ ] okay it made me feel
nothing okay I felt nothing I laughed I
drank wine I paused it multiple times
because I just didn't [ __ ] care but I
was invested in the beginning of it I
said that to you Citizen Kane I was
sitting there a [ __ ] bored I already
know where it's going and I've never
seen it at least Casablanca I was roped
in a little bit although the beginning
of it is very long and very boring and I
don't understand what's going on more of
the story when society tells Jenna that
you should like this you won't like it
is do I have a problem um I don't think
it's a problem this is a great thing and
I just like to tear down there it's a
very jetta characteristic and it's not
that it's not you put it very poorly
it's not like you just like to tear down
things because people say they're good
it's when people tell you to like
something or people tell you how to feel
about something because of their own
opinions or society's opinions about it
you are your knee-jerk isn't to get
excited to also enjoy your knee-jerk is
to okay well I want to take a look at it
through my [ __ ] eyes and you can back
off while I look at it yeah in that tone
but it did make you laugh when you came
home to hona semi drunk
Jenna and I'm like hey guess what what
guess what piping tea I have for you
Casablanca sucks
like for vodka so does with my friends
and I'm back and what the [ __ ] happened
like I don't even understand what
happens when you leave me alone I'll
even cut my hair very controversial
opinions porque no los dos but anyways
tell us about your your amazon situation
is not really a whole lot of development
as as of right now you've been following
the vlogs which I think you really all
should be following the vlogs but
basically I have this rack and it was
one of the first things I put up in the
new office because it's where I store
all my pins it's a retail rack so I I
hang my pins on it like it would be in a
in a store I hang it up I vlog I show
the office and the comment section gets
flooded with you guys telling me how
crooked I hung it and I'm like okay you
know what I know you guys love to do
this I mean you love to do you go in to
the vlog you find something and you just
pick it apart until I notice because
sometimes you'll do it and I'm just like
I brush it off in its but this was
overwhelming so I look at the constant I
okay alright so look at the rack and I
notice and this is not this is 1,000%
not the first time I noticed that the
rack itself had crooked bars but it is
the first time that I looked at it
seriously enough to do something about
it oh I thought you want me to explain
the whole snare no keep going oh no fine
whatever no so I called Amazon I gave
him a piece of my mind I was just like
hey like I've been subject to a lot of
embarrassment on the internet because of
this rack that you sold me many months
ago and I don't know what to do about it
because I there's no rehanging it it's a
crooked rack so they emailed me back
stay tuned for the next I'm just kidding
um no they emailed me back then they
were really nice about it and I kind of
felt bad but they were like hey like
sorry took us a while to get back to you
but we found you for the rack I know
it's been like six seven months but you
can have the money back for the rack
we're also adding some credit out of
your account for damages incurred on
your life you
you like you guilted that I didn't guilt
them all I wanted to them to do was
watch my youtube video and maybe
subscribe but they wouldn't like I
talked oh dude I was on the phone with
Rome Ramona and five different times I
asked her for Bezos I said why except
for Pope gimme base put me through but
then I also said I was like is there any
way I could just send you this link real
quick and like a chat or you know like
casually and then it got to the point
where I was like can you please watch my
youtube video and she just she was like
oh no I don't need to like I believe you
and like just avoiding it every every
turn she doesn't watch it she had no
interest in sorry no interest in my
youtube channel I'm really sorry so I
think the next step is I give him a call
hmm and I want to give him a big thanks
but also I'd like to I'd like to get to
the bottom of this really like who you
buying racks from that have bars that
are not angled straight and why are you
buying them and putting them under the
blanket fulfilled by Amazon supplied
tink LLC Co you're a troll I hate to
break it to you well you know it's
sometimes when you put the video up and
you do nothing wrong and everyone is
telling me you did something wrong
it drives you to take care of it and to
figure out a solution so that's I'm
doing I'm just picking a little and
figuring out solution what I can't thank
you seriously
good because then I then I um you don't
expect it what I do serious things like
a shark mm-hmm so stupid
so dumb just like Casablanca see the
difference is everyone agrees what I'm
saying is stupid is stupid not everyone
agrees that you can support those no no
I have a lot of people on my side
including Jeff bassist Jeff bass this is
not on your side on my side they refund
me there's nothing like calling Amazon
support and being like put me
help me through the bezos yeah I know
his extensions as people boop beep boop
boop boop hello is this Bezos hello and
Bezos I call customer support tell them
hi Bezos can you buzz me and I forgot my
key card to the office like Bezos goes
into the office of the keycard
it's his card signs in it like sir Sir
sir Sir also turns out the guys first
name is Bezos he has nothing to do with
Amazon those besos besos faceless he's
no relation to Jeff Bezos but I wish I
was spelled with an S baseless because
then it would be
is that what kisses is you think so Dino
Spanish you thought no poor can try that
not neo magenta me gusta por que
Castellano sir esta Hacienda Noel coma
city say just Bezos is una como a come I
come I get it whatever entire subscribe
well thank you guys for hanging out for
the new the new first podcast that was a
good sense yeah the new first ever
podcast in our new house in a podcast it
feels really good to be back
I know it was that difficult to not have
like a nice little weekly outlet you
know I mean I know I'm sorry if I said
anything that offended you about Casa
Blanca song I'm not sorry if she
offended you make sure to let her know
in the comments because I want her to
pay for that okay hold on hold on we're
in the trust tree yes all of us are a
family right here I need to smug
mama you can top us me disagree with
them but don't stifle okay let me speak
why everyone listening right now we're
all in the dig fam okay we're a family
mm-hmm that doesn't mean you can just
spout opinions and
the NSA it was a joke no it was all good
it's in good fun but don't rescind it
completely cuz I want you to keep I
didn't buy it what made you think I
rescinded my you said it was a joke yeah
I mean it's like it's a joking joke haha
like I think Casablancas terrible like
it's that's that's a joke you know II
mean yeah no I get it I just I want you
to like you're you have good opinions
like don't don't take him back as I'm
saying I didn't take him back all right
she didn't take him back what I'm saying
it's it's funny it's meant to be
something funny well it's not to be like
a serious critique well this podcast is
very serious always very serious so
please know you know where you are this
is a serious this place that we like to
take ourselves very seriously
all right well we would like to welcome
you our guests come on in
I thought you said they were coming
there's the guest here well text basis
about it yeah I heard a couple echoes
and I know it'll get better we're gonna
sound foam that whole wall parts of that
wall and potentially get curtains so
every wall has some sort of sound
absorbing so it's not like you know yeah
plus if if there are any movies that you
want us to watch for real with my like
next week I've never actually seen Mary
Poppins by the way okay don't make that
no no I was just
hey or have you if there's any old older
like black and white movies that you
would like oh yeah I have a feeling that
you guys are gonna nail it around the
head give like great suggestions right
away about what we should watch on that
next people do it we should do it yeah
so we have to sit down watch a movie on
our phones probably why because I have
to order them all to Amazon because
you're not on Hulu or Netflix so there
are Amazon I know a guy these days us
thank you guys for hanging out if you're
interested in getting video lights for
your own home or production or podcast
or whatever you need to light at home
I will link aperture below
um and we'll see you guys next week for
another podcast hopefully is sounding a
little bit better
you guys have a wonderful week now see
on Twitter bye
[Music]